sie kennen sich lange
wir sind glaube ich gleichzeitig in den
Bundestag gewählt wurden 1994 noch in
Bonn damals in demnächst nächstes Jahr
30 Jahre und duzen sich ja mir tut es
uns ja also der Peter und der Champ und
haben sie haben sie gleich gemerkt dass
er auch so ein Grünanteil in seiner
Wolle hat in seiner politischen ich habe
vorhin einfach gemerkt dass er in netter
Kerl ist und das ist eine ehrliche Haut
ist und das ist alles nicht wichtige
Kategorien in der Politik oder
also ich beurteile meine Mitmenschen
nicht danach welches Parteibuch sie
haben sondern erstmal danach ob man mit
denen irgendwie vernünftig schwätzen
können reden können und ob einer jetzt
immer sagt die eigene Partei immer Recht
und die anderen sind dämlich oder eben
das nicht und ich glaube uns beide
verbindet dass wir beide nicht immer nur
sagen die eigenen haben immer bei allem
Recht und die anderen sind alle dämlich
also für mich war das eigentlich eher
unpolitisch sogar wir waren beide auf
einer sehr politischen Veranstaltung
katholische Akademie Stuttgart Hohenheim
zum Ausländerrecht und haben
unterschiedliche Positionen vorgetragen
und dann war es so der Chamber da zu
Hause ich musste zum Stuttgarter
Hauptbahnhof das war eine elende
Fahrerei mit Taxis und Bussen und
ähnlichem und dann sagte der du ich habe
eine Ente in zwei TV ich bringe dich zum
Hauptbahnhof und das war
völlig völlig unerwartet wir haben uns
damals glaube ich noch gesetzt sogar und
dann hat schon mehr der sicherlich auch
andere Termine hatte mich dem
politischen Gegner dorthin gebracht wir
sind dann halbes Jahr später gemeinsam
in Rheine ähm in Nordrhein-Westfalen auf
einer in einem Streitgespräch gewesen
zum Thema Integrationspolitik da haben
wir eigentlich weniger gestritten als
uns viel mehr ergänzt in dem was wir
vorgetragen haben und für mich war das
einfach ein Beispiel dass man eben
politische Gegner ernst nimmt und dass
man sie auf einer menschlichen Ebene vor
allen Dingen und ernst nimmt und das
habe ich in dem Fall auch nie bereut
und hat sich da was verändert sie sind
jetzt schon ein paar Tage raus
vielleicht die Frage vorweg vermissen
sie da was oder haben Sie das Gefühl
glücklicherweise nein ich glaube das was
jetzt gerade ist alles anständig ich
glaube ich kann sagen ich habe meine
Milch gegeben ich war 27 Jahre Bundestag
noch wieder Champ aber ich hatte eben
das Glück und oder das Privileg oder
auch die die Verpflichtung mich dann in
den 16 Jahren der Regierungszeit von
Angela Merkel einbringen zu können und
einbringen zu dürfen das habe ich getank
aller Kraft insofern
sofern nein es fehlt mir nicht weil ich
ja die Möglichkeit habe auf andere Weise
mitzuwirken indem ich mit Menschen
spreche indem ich meine Meinung Kultur
und jetzt ist sozusagen die andere
Generation an der Reihe das ist
demokratisch verwechsel und ich glaube
das ist kein großer Traurigkeit ist und
wenn Sie schauen auf das worüber wir
jetzt auch gleich sprechen werden die
die vielen ungelösten Probleme schauen
sie da manchmal da hätte ich härter
bleiben sollen das hätten wir knacken
sollen diese Nuss hätten wir mit Blick
auch auf die Verfasstheit dieses Landes
die hätten wir knacken müssen ja also
erst einmal wer Politik macht wer
Entscheidungen trifft der macht auch
Fehler das glaube ich habe es habe ich
auch nie verhält noch nie bestritten und
trotzdem wir haben natürlich auch viele
Nüsse geknackt in dieser Zeit Denken
voraus dass man eigentlich alle Nüsse
knacken kann die man knacken möchte und
gerade die Probleme der Regierung jetzt
im Augenblick und dass ich mich
inhaltlich jetzt da einmische äh zeigen
doch dass kein Minister und keine Partei
alleine entscheiden kann welche Politik
gemacht wird wir haben wenn es um die
AFD geht ein Fehler gemacht und es
versemmelt nach der Wahl 2017 ich glaube
damals war die Chance dass die AFD sich
selbst dem Maske hoch und dann haben wir
in der Regierung damals Monate lang über
die Sommerpause Schritten über das Thema
Ausländerpolitik und Flüchtlingspolitik
das war der Masterplan Asyl sie erinnern
sich damals Frau Nahles unter Seehofer
und die übrige Regierung die haben alle
aus persönlicher Überzeugung gehandelt
aber es hat viele Menschen abgeschreckt
und jetzt haben wir seit ungefähr zwei
Monaten eine heftige Diskussion die
immer noch nicht beendet ist und gelöst
ist vor allen Dingen innerhalb der
Koalition und so etwas hat dann
natürlich auch Rückwirkungen auf die
politische Kultur insgesamt und deshalb
habe ich immer die Auffassung vertreten
über regierungs- und oppositionsgrenzen
hinweg müssen wir auch den Mut haben als
demokratische staatsfragende Parteien
zusammenzuarbeiten und das betraf die
Zeiten als die Grünen Opposition waren
wo wir sehr viel mit den Grünen zusammen
gemacht hatten etwa auch mit Jürgen
Trittin damals und mit anderen grünen
Verantwortlichen als ich Umweltminister
war und das betrifft jetzt die Situation
denn die Aufgaben sind so groß dass eine
einzige Partei alleine sie gar nicht
wird lösen können so bevor wir richtig
reingehen Frau Löhr sie als jemand der
das ganze Geschehen auch schon sehr
lange und sehr intensiv beobachte sie
macht glaube ich einen alten
öfter aus nächster Nähe auch erlebt
Auslandsreisen und so weiter
können Sie sich an eine Zeit erinnern in
der das politische Klima jemals so
verhärtet war wie es im Moment ist in
dem man sich so
verbiestert gegenüberstand indem man
wenn man das Gefühl hatte dass es
langsam so wird wie ich selber ist das
erste Mal wahrgenommen habe 2016 in den
USA kurz vor der Wahl von Trump dann
brexit hat alles was da war jetzt
handeln wir uns von Krise zu Krise und
das Gefühl man steht sich immer
unversöhnlicher gegenüber jeder nimmt
für sich in Anspruch die Wahrheit
gepachte zu haben und man ist und das
ist eigentlich das schlimmste daran gar
nicht mehr bereit im anderen zuzuhören
gar nicht mehr die Möglichkeit in
Betracht zu ziehen dass er Recht haben
könnte
also das was wir jetzt in den letzten
zwei bis drei Monaten erleben diese
Debatte um das heizungsgesetz dass es in
der Tat was das habe ich so auch noch
nicht erlebt also es gab zu Zeiten der
großen Koalition gab es auch schon die
ein oder andere Stichelei auch die CDU
Herr Altmaier und Herr Scholz waren sich
nicht immer einig und haben versucht
sich da ja so ein bisschen gegenseitig
die Butter vom Brot zu nehmen so wie es
eben auch zum politischen Geschäft
gehört jetzt haben wir eine drei
Parteien Konstellation mit zwei sehr
unterschiedlichen kleinen Partnern die
FDP die auf den freiheitsaspekt pocht
die Grünen die eine Neigung dazu haben
gerne
detailliert vorzugeben die bestimmte
Dinge zu laufen haben also von daher ist
es jetzt nicht verwunderlich dass mehr
Diskussion ist und ich finde es auch
nicht also es ist nicht schlecht dass
diskutiert und vielleicht auch
gestritten wird solange es halt um die
Sache geht also das ist ja Teil der
Demokratie erleben jetzt im Moment in
dieser ganzen Debatte und das
heizungsgesetz die unterschiedlichen
gesellschaftlichen Positionen die einen
sagen totale Klima Panik wir müssen
sofort unser Leben komplett ändern und
andere sagen ja jetzt mal halblang so
ein bisschen was machen und dann passt
es Schaltplan da ist eine richtige Wut
also wenn man mal reinhört die Leute
haben eine richtige Wut das ist
unglaubliche gut mir hat heute jemand
gesagt der in Österreich lebt bezeichnet
dabei ich habe das Gefühl ihr in
Deutschland ihr seid so ein Kochtopf der
der brodelt und demnächst macht es Kabul
ja es geht halt jetzt also das eines der
Probleme ist dass die aktuelle Regierung
und spezielle harberg hat den zweiten
Schritt vor dem ersten macht also es
gibt einen oder es gab jetzt diesen
Gesetzentwurf zum heizungsgesetz der die
privaten Hauseigentümer in die Pflicht
nehmen schon ab nächstem Jahr wenn die
Heizung kaputt geht sich komplett
umzustellen dann wurde gleich gesagt
aber für Krankenhäuser und für soziale
Einrichtungen soll es Ausnahmen geben
dann wurde gesagt die Kommunen können
sich mit ihrer Fernwärme Planung noch
Zeit lassen das hätte alles von Anfang
an weil sie in ein Paket gehört mitsamt
der Förderung für Geringverdiener das
ist halt nicht passiert das ist eines
der Probleme das andere ist dass wir
gerade auch so ein bisschen den Kampf
der Egos erleben die FDP hat jetzt
schlecht abgeschnitten bei den Wahlen
und da ist jetzt so eine ein Bemühen und
Profilierung da und dann eskaliert das
dann halt auch sprachlich also dann
spricht Herr Scheffler von der Atombombe
die dieses heizungsgesetz ist dann die
Heizung Stasi ja und die heizpolizei
treten also das hat jetzt auch
sprachlich ein Niveau erreicht
glaube ich der politischen Debatte nicht
gut tut und was dann eben in der Tat
schädlich ist weil die Leute im Land
einfach total frustriert sind bevor wir
da noch mal wirklich reingehen die die
größere Ebene sozusagen weg vom Parteien
haben Sie das Gefühl her als sie mir und
der hat trifft ja auch ihre grüne Partei
an an vielen Stellen also so sehr
sozusagen die einen sagen das müssen wir
so machen sie Frau löschbaren gerade von
von Klima Panik und wir haben keine Zeit
mehr letzte Generation und so weiter ist
das Stichwort alle treiben jeden vor
sich her haben sie nicht manchmal das
Gefühl wir überfordern gerade dieses
Land ich habe dieser Tage in den
Kommentar gelesen von ich glaube Harald
Martenstein warst der sagte was ist
eigentlich los mit diesem Land
Deutschland glaubt dass wir unbegrenzte
Migration verkraften können obwohl es
kein einziges historisches Beispiel
dafür gibt da gleichzeitig wollen wir
den Sozialstaat immer weiter ausbauen
wir wollen keine Erhöhung des
Rentenalter sie wollen mehr Geld für
Kinder und parallel dazu stellen wir die
komplette Energieversorgung
alles hochindustrie Landes auf Sonne und
auf windum und kriegen es aber nicht mal
hin unsere Behörden endlich mal ins
Computerzeitalter zu beamen und wir
kriegen auch die Alphabetisierung
unserer Kinder nicht hin und wenn das
alles nicht funktioniert dann sagen wir
pass auf wir haben eine Idee wir müssen
jetzt einfach die Steuern erhöhen wir
nehmen es den Reichen weg und wenn die
dann irgendwann ins Ausland gehen mit
ihren Millionen und Milliarden sagen wir
das gibt's doch gar nicht wie könnt ihr
sowas machen bei Deutschland ist doch so
toll hat er recht
ich glaube erstmal dass beide Seiten
recht haben es gibt ja manchmal es ist
halt nun mal so das Land ist die
viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt und
wenn wir weiterhin das bleiben wollen
müssen wir ein paar Sachen ändern wir
haben leider immer noch Kupferkabel
statt Glasfaser wir haben die Situation
dass wir Züge haben die sind nicht
elektrifiziert ich meine ich bin in
Deutschland offen im Zug unterwegs ich
fahre oft wenn ich wichtige Termine habe
zwei Züge vorher damit ich eine Chance
habe halbwegs anzukommen es gab mal eine
Zeit da war Deutschland in der Welt
berühmte für Ordnung Verlässlichkeit etc
was ist damit passiert immer so die
könnte viele Beispiele anfügen sie haben
die Schulen genannt ich habe selber zwei
schulpflichtige Kinder werden während
Corona gesehen dass die Digitalisierung
da nicht angekommen ist wenn ich zum
Arzt gehe muss ich meine Röntgen
Berichte mitnehmen weil wir die digitale
Patientenakte noch nicht haben so das
ist das eine das erfordert wahnsinnige
Veränderung dass wir wegkommen von
russischen Gas bedeutet ja auch dass wir
schneller in die Erneuerbaren rein
müssen auf der anderen Seite gibt es
welche die haben aber auch recht die
sagen ihr seid viel zu langsam die
Klimakrise die drückt ihr macht die
Chance eine künftigen Generation kaputt
und das in ein gesundes Gleichgewicht zu
bringen das ist unsere Aufgabe aber die
Alternative kann ja jetzt nicht sein
dass ich einfach mich zurücklehne und
nichts macht davon hat man jetzt glaube
ich genug das hat dem Land nicht gut
getan wir müssen die Veränderung machen
aber die Kritiker
mitnehmen
Leute verweigern sich die Leute sagen
mir zu schnell das überfordert mich
alles das Problem ist wir haben eine
Koalition wo drei Partner sehr
unterschiedliche Ansichten haben so wie
ich der Meinung bin dass das was ich
mache jetzt nicht so ganz falsch ist
haben sie anderen halt auch so und das
ist halt aber
das eine ist doch dass die Regierung ein
Gesetz umsetzen muss dass die große
Koalition gemacht hat das geltende
klimaschutzgesetzen
vom Bundestag beschlossen worden nach
einem Urteil aus Karlsruhe übrigens dann
nochmal gegengestimmt weil sie sagen es
ist nicht streng genug geht nicht
schnell genug nach der Wahl in der Ampel
haben sich akzeptiert das sind unsere
alten Klimaziele und die müsste jede
Regierung umsetzen wir können aus meiner
Sicht gar nicht klar genug sagen dass
die klimakleber gegen Gesetze verstoßen
und das geahndet werden muss aber dann
können wir doch nicht sagen wenn wir als
Politiker eingesetzt umsetzen müssen
interessiert es uns nicht die zweite
Frage ist super und das ist das was die
Leute was die Leute auf die Palme
bringen ich mache immer den Discounter
den Test habe ist mehr Zeit zum
Einkaufen gehen und mich dann Leute
erkennen sprechen Sie mich an egal wo
das Essen sondern die Leute haben Angst
um ihre Besitzstände um ihre
Lebensleistung und ich weiß ja wohl dass
in dem Gesetz viele Regelungen was
Zuschüsse angeht und auch Ausnahmen
angeht sind aber das überblickt ja
niemand ich weiß ja auch bis heute
niemand wie die Einigung zwischen
fdp-gründen und SPD am Ende Bundestages
aussehen wird
das ist die große Sorge der
Mittelschicht das sind Facharbeiter das
im Rentner das sind Familien mit Kindern
ja und die sagen müssen wir jetzt unsere
gesamte Lebensleistung die
Eigentumswohnung die paar tausend Euro
auf der hohen Kante die wir für die
Ausbildung der Kinder reserviert hatten
müssen wir die einsetzen wenn die
nächste Heizung angeschafft werden soll
und da muss es glaube ich Garantien
geben dass niemand ein Sonderopfer
bringt und seine Lebensleistung
einsetzen muss sondern dass wir diese
Energieziele gemeinsam erreichen und
dann brauchen wir Prioritäten und
posterioritäten das heißt wir können
nicht wenn wir sagen Klimapolitik ist
wichtig wenn wir sagen die Sicherheit
für die Menschen die etwas geleistet
haben in ihrem Leben ist wichtig dann
können wir uns nicht noch 100.000 andere
stecken Pferde leisten die die Pferde
Schäume machen und müssen sagen jetzt
wird einmal das eine oder andere nicht
vorrangig behandelt bis wir die Lösung
haben für das was die Leute bringen
überfordern aber das Problem ist doch
das ist jetzt nicht ganz die Position
wie ist die Opposition im Bundestag
gerade vertritt das vertritt
wahrscheinlich der Ministerpräsident der
Nordrhein-Westfalen wüsst du das
Vertreter Günther so und
Schleswig-Holstein nein der von der
Union das auch gut bezahlt werden
also ich fühle mich da in der CDU ein
guter Gesellschaft er hat sie ja genannt
Hendrik gewusst und Daniel Günther und
auch andere die wir in Verantwortung
haben aber ich könnte natürlich jetzt
auch ich will ja nicht gemeinsam sein
zum gemeinsam zu meinem Bekannten sagen
und das ausgerechnet dann Winfried
Kretschmann den Wirtschaftsminister
kritisiert hat und gesagt hat mach mal
halblang war natürlich dann auch Wasser
auf die Mühlen vieler Kritiker man kann
im Übrigen jedes Gesetz der Ampel
durchaus hinterfragen und kritisieren
und ich hätte mir persönlich auch
gewünscht dass man bei öffentlichen
Gebäuden voranmarschiert wäre dass man
vor allen Dingen den Bürgern die
Möglichkeit der Fernwärme Anschlüsse
geboten hätte ich habe das nicht bei mir
zu Hause weil es auch gar nicht ob das
kommt und wann das kommt
aber eines will ich deutlich machen man
muss den politischen Gegner immer in
seiner Würde respektieren und was sie im
Augenblick sehen ist doch das gerade bei
den sehr rechtsextremen bei den sehr
weit am rechten Rand vertretenen Wählern
Unterstützung der AFD in einer Art und
Weise die persönliche Integrität auch
des Wirtschaftsministers in Frage
gestellt wird die wir als Demokraten
gemeinsam nicht zulassen dürfen
eine kurze Nachfrage sie sagten gerade
sie werden sich da ein guter
Gesellschaft mit Hendrik Wüste und
anderen Friedrich Merz haben sie nicht
erwähnt in dem Zusammenhang ist das
keine gute Gesellschaft also doch
Friedrich Merz hat zum Beispiel dafür
gesorgt dass wir wesentliche Teile der
ampelpolitik für die die eine Mehrheit
brauchten etwa die 100 Milliarden für
die Bundeswehr gemeinsam
parteiübergreifend verabschiedet haben
zweitens Friedrich Merz hat vorgestern
erklärt ganz öffentlich äh das ist eine
Brandmauer zur AFD gibt und das ist
keine Zusammenarbeit der CDU in welcher
Form auch immer mit der AFD in Zukunft
geben wird das ist finde ich verdient
Anerkennung in der Frage der Klima lange
er Chef ist war der Zusage der
Klimapolitik gibt es zwei ungelöste
die eine richtet sich an die FDP die
jetzt ja die CDU in der Opposition auf
überholt oder versucht den Eindruck zu
erwecken und natürlich auch an uns
selber nämlich wenn wir das ablehnen was
Herr Habeck vorgelegt hat wie wollen wir
diese Klimaziele sicher erreichen wir
wollen stattdessen machen
man kann alles ablegen und sagen das ist
nicht ideal aber dann muss man andere
Maßnahmen vorschlagen die zu dem Ziel
führen und äh die Regierung ich glaube
schon dass die Regierung an der
Verantwortung hat auf die anderen
Parteien in der Opposition das heißt die
cdu/csu zuzugehen und zu sagen lass uns
das gemeinsam machen denn es führt ja
auch zu nichts wenn wir jetzt in vier
Jahren eine neue Regierung bekämmen wenn
die alles wieder rückgängig macht und
von vorne wieder anfängt haben Sie das
Gefühl ich höre das nicht zum ersten Mal
vielleicht frage ich erstmal Frau Löhr
haben sie Frau Löhr das Gefühl er wird
zu wenig miteinander geredet das heißt
auch im politischen Betrieb im
Hintergrund wird dieser Tiefe der da
auch in der großen Gesellschaft
entstanden ist in gewisser Weise auch
sichtbar ich frage das deswegen weil ich
das hier häufiger höre die Klage von
unionsvertretern die sagen gerade bei
diesen grünen die sind so arrogant wir
kriegen keinen Draht zu diesen Leuten
wir können mit denen ich rede gucken sie
nicht so entsetzt man nicht sehen aber
für interessieren ja also das heißt man
redet nicht mehr miteinander woran auch
immer es liegt aber das ist keine gute
Nachricht also das gilt für einzelne
Handeln eine Person aber es geht mit
Sicherheit nicht für alle also es gibt
ja auch von der Pizza Connection die
schonärzte mehr und Peter Altmaier
verbunden hat inzwischen die dritte
Auflage wo also jüngere CDU-Abgeordnete
und grün Abgeordneter sich weiter in
einem jetzt in einem Restaurant in
Berlin Mitte treffen und sich durchaus
unterhalten also da sind nach wie vor
Drähte da es gibt halt einige ich will
immer scharf machen in den Parteien die
dann halt auch verbal eben da in die
Vollen gehen und die dann vielleicht den
gesprächskanal der im Hintergrund
aufgebaut wurde dann mit der ein oder
anderen Äußerung dann wieder hinweg fing
aber ich finde das interessant wie Herr
Altmaier das jetzt gerade so darstellt
weil wenn sie der also wenn sie der
Klimaschützer als Minister gewesen wären
als der Sie sich hier so präsentieren
dann werden wir hätten wir viele der
Diskussionen die wir jetzt heute führen
hätten wir nicht also ich glaube ein
Grundproblem ist dass die Regierung
Merkel und damit auch sie quasi
Klimaschutz darauf beschränkt haben
zahlen in Gesetze zu schreiben
Klimaneutralität 2050 dann 2045
Kohleausstieg 2038 aber es haben halt
dann die Punkte gefehlt die Schritte
dahin also was bedeutet das denn dann
praktisch
sprechen können sie hatten dann ein Jahr
lang keinen energiestaatssekretär dann
wurde der Windkraftausbau erstmal
abgeblockt also da ist einfach vieles
liegengeblieben und ich glaube
Industrie
ganz verschieden
fertig machen ich glaube das ist so ein
bisschen jetzt auch das Problem was
Robert Habeck hat er hat halt jetzt
diese vier Jahre von denen er selbst
sagt so das ist jetzt die Chance
wirklich was zu bewirken im Land und er
will halt jetzt das wofür andere Länder
viele Jahre gebraucht haben zum Beispiel
was die Fernwärme angeht das will er
halt jetzt in kurzer Zeit durchsetzen
die Briten verhandeln auch gerade über
den Umstieg bei den Heizungen auf die
Erneuerbaren aber die planen dann erst
Veränderungen im Bestandsgebäuden ab
2035 also die wollen den Leuten 10 Jahre
Zeit lassen sich darauf einzustellen da
sagen halt jetzt die Grünen so viel Zeit
haben wir nicht aber der prallen halt
jetzt auch diese Welten aufeinander es
ist in der vergangenen Regierung sehr
wenig passiert es gab viele Gipfel es
gab Kater es gab Strategiepapiere alles
mögliche aber praktisch ist halt nichts
passiert
gesamtgesellschaftlich der Versuch
sozusagen das größere Bild zu malen was
passiert da gerade sie sagen der trifft
sozusagen eine Politik die jetzt machen
muss und ist ja sehr interessant worauf
Peter Altmaier gerade hingewiesen hat
also wenn man Teile der FDP hört wenn
man auch Teile der Union zum Teil hört
hat man das Gefühl also
heizungswände wärmewende Heizung
umstellen wo kommt denn das plötzlich
her was ist denn das für eine neue
spinnerte verrückte grüne Idee willst du
noch mal sagen also dieses
Klimaschutzgesetz ist 219 schon in der
großen Koalition beschlossen worden oder
dann noch mal verschärft sieht vor dass
Deutschland im Jahr 2045
klimaneutral sein muss und dem Gesetz
steht auch dass wir die CO2-Emissionen
aus fossilen Brennstoffen bereits bis 20
30 und fast ein Drittel reduziert haben
müssen und das Interessante daran ist ja
das muss jede Regierung das müsste auch
ein Kanzler März so machen das müsste
jede Regierung dieses Landes müsste das
genauso machen also so zu tun als wäre
sozusagen
den Grünen jetzt die böse wärmewende und
bei den anderen dann geht es ohne das
ist quatsch das ist Schmu den Leuten da
erzählt wird
man hat aber das Gefühl ein großer Teil
des Landes will das auch so gerne
glauben wir möchten eigentlich keine
Zumutungen oder was ist es ja was lang
war Klimaschutz halt was sehr abstraktes
also eben das wurde auf Papiere
geschrieben in Gesetze geschrieben und
auf wundersame Weise hat man dann
gehofft dass ich das schon von selbst
einstellen wird und natürlich haben wir
auch Politiker lange Zeit die
öffentliche Debatte darüber gescheut was
das eigentlich bedeutet also zum einen
dass es viel Geld kostet wie viel Geld
das kostet wer das zahlen soll das
Geringverdiener Unterstützung bekommen
das aber die die etwas mehr Geld haben
das auch aus eigener Tasche zahlen
müssen darüber wurde halt nicht
gesprochen und das ist auch zum Thema
Dringlichkeit Entschuldigung gesagt
dieser Tage es ist eben gerade nicht so
dass morgen die Welt untergeht wenn wir
den nächsten zehn Jahren das klingt noch
weitere zehn Jahre Entspannung ja die
Weichen richtigstellen guten Weg
Politikbereich geben du bist mir nicht
böse lieber Peter Altmaier
in der Regierungszeit von Frau Merkel
hat die Borchardt Kommission benannt
nach dem ehemaligen
Landwirtschaftsminister unter Helmut
Kohlen Bericht vorgelegt Inflationsrate
0,5% sprudelnde Steuereinnahmen des
Staat wusste nicht was man im Geld
machen soll aufgrund der Zinseinnahmen
ich habe jetzt eine Situation dass wir
der Finanzminister mein Haushalt schön
kürzt weil wir den Haushalt sanieren
müssen und wir haben die Inflationsrate
von 7% und wir haben gerade eben ja
gesehen Krieg vor unseren Nase so jetzt
muss ich diesen Bericht Umsetzen in
einer dramatisch erschwerten Situation
und meine schärfsten Kritiker sind die
die damals mit einer optimalen Situation
diesen Bericht nicht umgesetzt haben
ähnliches gilt Zukunftskommission
Landwirtschaft das erst die Naturschutz
Seite drin da saß die Landwirtschaft
drin die Wissenschaft drin wichtigen
Leute die haben einen dicken Bericht
vorgelegt der eigentlich das Programm
Alter demokratischen Parteien sein
müsste und der Landwirtschaft mit
Zukunft zu geben und Tierschutz
Naturschutz zusammenzubringen etwas
vernünftig machen muss mit Maß und Mitte
diesen Bericht an meine Vorgänger im
Regal wo sich hin stauben lassen jetzt
versuche ich das umzusetzen und ich bin
ja ganz bei dir ich glaube dass wir
solche Fragen nicht mit 51 Prozent gegen
49 Prozent entscheiden können weil
Mittelstand die Bauern alle brauchen
planungsinvestitionssicherheit das setzt
voraus ich sage das auch selbstkritisch
wir müssen aufpassen dass wir die
Gesellschaft nicht überfordern
nicht ich komme aus Baden-Württemberg
wir arbeiten so und auf der anderen
Seite ist aber auch wichtig dass
diejenigen die heute Opposition sind
immer wissen wenn sie morgen Regierung
sind dann trifft die Klimakrise dann
trifft Waldbrände dann trifft
Wassermangel dann trifft das Problem
dass wir auch in 10 20 50 Jahren noch
ernten brauchen sie genauso und wenn man
das hinkriegen dann gibt's immer noch
genug wo wir streiten können aber wir
handeln zum Wohle des